قال الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني ان اكثر من
100 120 ساعه مرت ولا يزال مجهولا مصير
فريق متطوعي الذي خرج لانقاذ الطفل هند
ونشد الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني المجتمع
الدولي التدخل الفوري للضغط على سلطات
الاحتلال للكشف عن مصير الطفله هند ذات
الست سنوات
وطاقم
الاسعاف من رام الله مبال فرسخ مديره
الاعلام في الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني سيده
مبال هل وصلتكم اي معلومات اي مؤشرات حتى
الان تفيد بمصير الطفله هند والطاقم الذي
سعى
لانقاذها مساء الخير لك ولكل المشاهدين
للاسف يعني حتى ه اللحظه نحن نعيش اجواء
من القلق على مصير زملائنا الذين خرجوا في
مهمه انسانيه وحتى هذه اللحظه لم يعودوا
ليس فقط على زملائنا وانما على طفله لم
تتعد سته اعوام استغاثت بنا استغاثت
بالهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني لعده ساعات وهي
تعيش اجواء من الهلع والرعب قبل خمسه ايام
خرج الفريق في مهمه انسانيه لم يعودوا
منها حتى هذه اللحظه احمد ويوسف فريق
اسعاف الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني وصلوا الى
المكان الذي تتواجد به السياره التي توجد
بداخلها الطفله هند اعلمو بانهم يستطيعون
رؤيه السياره التي لا تبعد عنهم سوى بضعه
امتار ومنذ ذلك الحين فقد الاتصال فقد
الاتصال واخر ما سمعه الفريق الذي كان على
اتصال معهم اصوات اطلاق نار في المكان
ومنذ ذلك الحين وحتى هذه اللحظه ونحن نجهل
فريق مصير الفريق الذي توجه لانقاذ الطفله
هند لا نعلم ماذا حل بالطفله هند او حتى
بيوسف واحمد مسعفي الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني نتساءل ان كانوا على قيد الحياه
هل من الممكن ان يكون الاحتلال قد قام
باستهدافهم هل من الممكن ان يكون قد
اعتقلهم واعتقلت طفله هند كل هذه الاسئله
نريد اجابه واضحه عليها ولا احد يستطيع
الاجابه على هذا السؤال سوى الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الذي لا يزال حتى هذه اللحظه
يت واجد في المنطقه التي تم بها استهداف
عائله الطفله من حتى سده حتى الان الجانب
الاسرائيلي ينكر اي معرفه له بمصير الطفله
ومن جاء
لانقاذها ما هي اهم او اخطر
مخاوفكم المخاوف هي ان يكونوا قد تم
استهدافهم كما تم استهداف العائله باكملها
عائله الطفله هند حيث كان قد اطلق
الاحتلال النار على كل من كان
بداخل المركبه وبقيت هند وحيده وقد شهد
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني على عمليه اطلاق
النار من قبل الاحتلال على الطفله التي
تبلغ من العمر 15 عاما والتي كانت لازالت
على قيد الحياه حينما وصلتنا مناشده
عائلتها احد اقاربها الذي اتصل وزودنا
برقم الهاتف قمنا بالاتصال بالرقم ردت
الطفله ليان لم تتجاوز ال 30 ثانيه قالت
توجد دبابات يطلقون النار علينا وثم سمعنا
صرخات الطفله حينما تم اطلاق النار بشكل
كثيف عليها الى ان استشهدت على الفور
وفارقت الحياه استطعنا استكمال الاتصال
ومعاوده الاتصال مره اخرى لترد الطفله هند
التي كانت في حاله من الرعب والهلع لا
يمكن ان تتخيل لطفل في هذا العالم ان
يعيشها شهدت الطفله هند اطلاق النار على
جميع من كان في داخل المركبه حدثتنا عن
خوفها من الدبابات التي كانت تحاصر المكان
حدثتنا عن لحظات الرعب التي عاشتها وكانت
تردد باستمرار تعالوا خذوني تعالوا خذوني
في لحظات شعرنا بها بالعجز لانه لم يكن
بامكاننا الذهاب الى هذه المنطقه التي
يعتبرها الاحتلال منطقه عسكريه يمنع وصول
مركبه الاسعاف اليها او ايا كان ويقوم
باستهداف اي شخص يحاول التحرك في هذه
المنطقه حصلنا على التنسيق ومن ثم بعد ان
اعطي لنا الضوء الاخضر توجهت مركبه اسعاف
الهلال الاحمر الى المكان وحتى هذه اللحظه
لا يزال مصير فريق الاسعاف والطفله هند
مجهولا نحن نحمل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
المسؤوليه عن سلامه طاقم اسعاف الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني وعن سلامه الطفله هند
القانون الدولي الانساني واضح المدنيين
والعاملين في مجال العمل الانساني والعمل
الطبي هم فئات محميه يجب احترامها
وحمايتها وليس استهدافها نحن اختبرنا
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في تجارب صفقه حتى
هذه اللحظه 11 شخصا بالهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني استشهدوا وهم على راس عملهم هذا
يعني ان الاحتلال بكل اكيد وفي تجارب
سابقه قام باطلاق النار على مسعفين حتى مع
وجود عمليه تنسيق مسبق